Hello everyone.
Welcome to the Lange Focus Channel and
my name is Paul today.
This is not a feature video.
This is just a special video in which
I'm going to make a little announcement
and then I'm going to answer some
frequently asked questions that a lot of
people ask me in the comments of videos
and also in private messages.
So the first announcement that I want to
make is that I have created a patriotic
account.
Now maybe you don't know what Patrion
is.
Patrion is a service that allows you to
basically support your favorite youtube
creators by pledging to give them a
certain amount of money each month and
amount of money that you decide.
Now I want to say right away,
you don't have to do this.
You don't have to give any money.
This is basically like a voluntary
subscription feed that you can pay if
you want,
but the amount is up to you so it can be
as little as $1.
That's one of the cool things about
Patrion is that everyone can give just
$1,
not everyone,
but if you want,
you can give $1 and if a lot of people
give $1,
then that amount of money kind of adds
up in the creator gets,
you know,
a significant amount.
So that's the cool thing about it.
It's kind of a collective way to support
your favorite creators as a team.
So the reason I'm doing that is because
I've put in a lot of time and effort
into making the videos and basically
that's a lot of time that I could be
putting into different work that pay
money.
I do get a little bit of money from some
advertising on youtube,
but it's just a small amount.
It's not really a lot,
uh,
because according to my statistics,
about 70% of people use ad blockers and
that's okay.
I don't really mind if you do that.
That's up to you.
Of course,
this is all voluntary.
If you want to support the channel,
Patrion is a way to do that.
Even if you like to use an ad blocker or
whatever,
things like that.
Basically have a look at the Patrion
page that I've created.
If you think that Lang focus deserves a
little donation every month,
a dollar or whatever you want to give
them,
that would be highly appreciated.
But if not,
then don't worry about it because I'll
still love you just as much.
She'll still be a valued viewer and all
of that,
so don't even stress about it.
It's completely voluntary.
And the link to that Patrion page is
down below in the description.
So onto a few frequently asked
questions.
So the first frequently asked question
is,
Paul,
how many languages do you speak?
Now this is a strange question to be
asked because it kind of feels like,
because I'm making the videos that
people think I'm a language master or a
language guru or one of those things,
and I don't think of myself like that.
I don't think I'm a language master.
I'm just someone who's very passionate
about languages and very interested in
them.
And I'm also very passionate about
learning because the teacher,
but also I just love learning.
But I know why people are asking that
question.
So I'll try to give you my answer.
I'll,
I'll tell you which language is that.
I've basically invested a lot of time
into studying that.
I've studied in depth in that I have a
significant amount of knowledge of it
doesn't mean I'm really advanced that
those languages,
but it means I put that time and effort
into them.
So the first one that I studied back in
the day was Hebrew.
In University I studied biblical Hebrew,
but in my free time I also studied
modern Hebrew.
I also studied biblical,
Aramaic and university and at the same
time I studied old English or Anglo
Saxon.
So we can throw that in there and it's
not a spoken language,
but I'll throw that in there.
I've also studied Arabic,
I studied modern standard Arabic and
also some Arabic dialects,
specifically Palestinian and to some
extent Egyptian as well.
I've also of course studied Japanese.
As you might know,
I live in Japan and I've been studying
Japanese for a long time.
I've also studied Indonesian.
I've also studied French.
I've also studied tagalog.
I've also studied Esperanto and I've
also recently been studying Italian.
So those are the ones I've really put
time and effort into studying quite a
lot.
I don't know if I'm forgetting any,
but uh,
that's probably the main ones.
There are other languages that I've
studied to a basic level,
but I don't really know them enough to
say that I know them.
And there are some languages that I can
also read.
Like I have passive knowledge of them
because I've studied related languages,
but I've never specifically studied
those languages themselves.
So for example,
Portuguese and Spanish,
I can,
I can often make sense to them when I'm
reading them,
but I've never studied them.
There are also other languages that I've
just studied from a linguistic point of
view.
Like I want to see how those languages
work.
So I examined them and sometimes the
language profile videos I make are kind
of like that.
Like I'm just interested in those
languages.
So I examine them and study and learn
about those languages.
But I haven't necessarily studied those
languages.
Basically I consider myself a language,
enthusiasm,
someone who loves languages.
I don't call myself a polyglot.
I'm not going to make a video called
Canadian guys speaks 25 languages or
something like that.
Like that's not really the purpose of
this channel.
That channel is called Lang focus
because I want to focus on the languages
and not really on me and my own ability.
Another frequently asked question I get
is Paul,
what do you do for a living?
Is it related to languages?
Well,
yes,
kind of a,
I'm an instructor at a university and I
teach English as a foreign language to
students in Japan.
So originally part of the reason I made
the length focus channel was kind of to
inspire my students so I have some
videos to show them and I could show
them that my hobby is language learning
and I could give them some extra
motivation to work hard to study English
because they could see that their
teacher is doing that to another
frequently asked question I get is Paul,
what's your educational background?
Well,
I have two university degrees.
My first university degree was in
English with a linguistics focus.
So it wasn't a literature degree.
It was a linguistics degree in the
English department.
So that means I studied the history of
English,
I studied English grammar,
I studied English phonology,
I studied a dialectal differences in
English.
I studied all of those kinds of things
about the English language.
I also had a minor in religious studies.
Basically all of my credits that went
towards that minor where courses in
biblical Hebrew and Biblical Aramaic.
I wanted to study those languages and I
figured out that I could get a minor in
religious studies by just taking those
courses.
So that's what I did.
I also have a second university degree
that one is in education.
So after I finished my first degree,
I went back to university and did a
second degree in education and that's
what allows me to be a teacher and do my
current job at the university.
So let's just a little bit about me.
It seems like some of the viewers want
to get to know a little bit more about
me personally.
If you're one of those people,
you can check out my instagram too,
like gives you a little bit of a glimpse
into my life,
my daily life,
and you can follow me on facebook as
well and all of those different social
media channels.
So thank you for watching.
Have a nice day.